nevada senator jackie rosen is urging  the national park service to open boat  ramps at lake mead because right now the  hemingway ramp is the only one that's  open and this is causing some major  backups for those who are trying to  visit the lake in some cases hours long  waits to launch a boat rosen says this  is putting a strain on local economies  dependent on outdoor recreation  the lake is going down and down and down  we have a lot of work to do on that but  it's impacting local tourism and it's  impacting those small businesses all  that ecosystem people driving on their  way to the lake whether they stop for  ice gas groceries whatever they are and  people are doing business on and around  the lake so we need to  press the director to find solutions  she went on to say quote the prolonged  closure of these boat ramps through  prime fishing season leaves many  recreationists cut off from the access  to the lake at the time of highest  demand